Traduttore: Antonella Corda
Revisore: Patrizia C Romeo Tomasini
Oggi non vi parlerò dell'antispecialista.
L'antispecialista sono io.
Io sono...
Potrei definirmi un'artista.
Nel mio lavoro quotidiano
utilizzo linguaggi molto diversi
e ho scelto di non specializzarmi
veramente in nessuno di questi.
È particolare per me essere qui oggi
perché quest'evento è organizzato
da un 'università, da studenti,
e l'università è per me un posto
dove i sogni vengono imbottigliati
in un prodotto vendibile con etichetta.
Per metterla in altre parole,
l'università è un posto
che scegliamo di frequentare
se vogliamo specializzarci in qualcosa,
qualcosa di nostra scelta, no?
Oggi vorrei parlarvi di questa scelta,
di questa scelta che tutti facciamo.
Quindi riflettendo su questo,
ho deciso di raccontarvi delle storie.
La prima storia non è nulla di nuovo,
è una storia che tutti conosciamo
perché tutti l'abbiamo vissuta
sulla nostra pelle.
Inizia più o meno così:
Eravamo piccoli
ed eravamo molto nuovi
su questo pianeta.
Eravamo appena arrivati
e ne stavamo ancora scoprendo,
con grande entusiasmo, le luci,
le ombre
e le superfici.
Mamma! Mamma, una formica!
Mamma, una formica!
Una formica, sì, sì...
Una formica.
Poi un giorno ci venne chiesto:
"Che cosa vuoi fare da grande?"
Beh, ognuno di noi quel giorno
scoprì due cose:
che sarebbe diventato grande
e che gli sarebbe toccato fare qualcosa
nella vita.
Ora, se noi avessimo avuto all'epoca
la prontezza di rispondere:
"Mamma, scusa, sto contando le formiche".
Invece no, i bambini adorano
questo tipo di domande, no?
È solo un'altra occasione
per fargli esplodere i neuroni.
Allora escono fuori cose bellissime
di questo tipo.
Qui sto citando due bambini
che conosco.
Frido, cosa vuoi fare da grande?
Il pilota!
Sono un po' lente le slides, scusate.
E tu, Rocco?
L'elefante
Per fortuna i nostri bambini
non hanno la minima idea
di che cosa sia
il mondo professionale adulto.
Perché noi quando chiediamo
ad un bambino: "Cosa vuoi fare da grande?"
non stiamo chiedendo
cosa vuol fare da grande.
Gli stiamo chiedendo
"Che lavoro vuoi fare da grande?"
"Che professione vuoi svolgere da grande?"
Se io chiedessi a mio figlio:
"Samuel, che cos'è il lavoro?"
Se potesse, sono quasi sicura
che mi risponderebbe così:
"Il lavoro è quella cosa che toglie
a te il tempo di stare con me".
Ebbene, andiamo avanti,
perché la storia va avanti.
Effettivamente cresciamo, scopriamo
che diventiamo grandi molto velocemente,
a volte più veloci di quanto si voglia.
Raggiungiamo un momento della nostra vita
in cui passiamo dall'essere bambini
all'essere ragazzi.
Questo momento viene definito pubertà:
è un momento in cui
la maggior parte di noi sprofonda
nella barbarie più putrida.
Forse voi qui a Roma siete
un po' più civili di noi,
ma io vengo dall'Alta Tuscia,
una zona molto...
un paesino di 5000 abitanti.
Alle scuole medie, da me,
si tiravano astucci da una parte all'altra
della stanza, si rovesciavano banchi,
si rovesciavano professori,
giuro. L'ho visto.
Si comincia a parlare di sesso, di droga,
si comincia a fumare,
si comincia a mancare di rispetto
nella maniera più svergognata
e deliberata.
Si comincia a esplorare...
Anzi, l'unico concetto
che si ha intenzione
di esplorare a quell'età
è il concetto di figo e non figo:
questo è figo, questo non è figo.
Bene, quello che succede
in questo periodo in cui i nostri bambini,
ragazzi, non si sa bene
che cosa sono,
è che è estremamente difficile
avere a che fare con loro.
per cui avviene da parte
del mondo adulto
quella che io chiamo un certo tipo
di selezione innaturale
e molto poco corretta
nei confronti dei nostri giovani.
Suona più o meno così:
"Sei un fannullone!
Non te ne farai niente
della tua vita!
Smettila di sognare adesso!"
Smettila di sognare?
Perché effettivamente
anche i nostri sogni crescono con noi.
Non siamo un palloncino
che si ingrandisce con il tempo,
anche il nostro contenuto emotivo
si ingrandisce con noi.
Cosa succede?
Succede che a un certo punto
i sogni diventano grandi
e grandi e grandi
e perdiamo un po' il controllo,
continuano a crescere e ci pieghiamo
sotto il peso dei nostri sogni
e ci sentiamo dei fessi
perché ci guardiamo intorno
e tutti gli altri camminano spigliati.
Ho da fare, tra tre minuti ho il treno.
Se lo perdo devo aspettare
altri cinque minuti.
E noi lì,
chini sotto il peso dei nostri sogni.
Perché i nostri sogni pesano?
Pesano perché ci rendiamo conto
che la realtà intorno a noi
non ha le risorse
per mantenerne le dimensioni.
Nessuno ci darà una mano
a tenere il peso dei nostri sogni.
Per cui, spesso,
prendiamo un decisione molto facile:
hop e via... ora devo prendere il treno,
scusate, ciao!
Andiamo avanti,
la storia va avanti.
Siamo più o meno alla fine
delle scuole superiori.
Penso che la maggior parte delle persone
qui si ricordino
di come ci si sente, no?
Cioé la maggior parte: siamo belli,
siamo brutti, siamo felici,
siamo depressi, siamo tutto insieme.
La maggior parte di noi non pensa
ad altro che all'altro sesso,
o allo stesso sesso, o al sesso e basta,
che in fondo è lo stesso,
e un giorno ci venne chiesto:
"Che cosa vuoi fare adesso?"
Oh! Ti stavo chiedendo una cosa.
Che cosa vuoi fare adesso?
Adesso sei grande.
Io? Sono grande?
Siamo diventati grandi,
apparentemente
siamo diventati grandi,
non ci siamo accorti di quando è successo.
Adesso l'aspettativa del mondo intero
ci crolla addosso,
dobbiamo avere una risposta.
Che cosa voglio fare? Cosa voglio fare?
Io... voglio studiare ingegneria.
Bravo!
Ora, il problema che io vedo è che
la risposta vera
non è veramente presa in considerazione.
Cioé, ripeto, quando ci viene chiesta
la domanda "Che cosa vuoi fare da grande?
Che lavoro vuoi fare?",
ci viene presentata una lista di risposte
tra le quali scegliere.
Una lista anche molto molto lunga,
ci da l'illusione che ci siano
tante possibilità.
In verità
le possibilità sono ancora di più.
Però quello che non è incluso nella lista
molto spesso non lo è... perché?
No, ma che idea, no?
Io vi posso elencare una serie
di risposte sbagliate, per esempio.
Una è questa: "Io da grande vorrei fare
il musicista".
Oppure ce n'è un'altra: "Io non so,
ho molteplici interessi.
Mi appassiono di astronomia,
ho un grande amore per la letteratura,
mi affascina il teatro".
Oh oh! Quante ne vuoi?
Ma vi è una terza risposta,
che secondo me è quella
che ognuno di noi teme un pochino,
che è questa:
"Io... non lo so"
Non lo sai?!
Ma ci siamo accorti di quanto
la risposta "Non lo so" ci spaventi?
Questa società
non accetta la possibilità
che si possa non sapere qualcosa.
Questo lo sanno i nostri bambini.
I nostri bambini crescono con il terrore
di non sapere abbastanza.
Terrore è una parola esagerata,
ma io mi ricordo essere bambina
e inventarmi le balle più assurde
pur di non dire
che non sapevo la risposta.
Anzi, vi è un esempio classico
che è quello lì di tipo fine elementari,
inizio scuole medie
in cui ci viene chiesto
"La capitale della Turchia?"
Io lo so ma non me lo ricordo.
Le balle più assurde pur di non ammettere
di non sapere qualcosa.
Ed io ero una di quelle bambine
che voleva sapere tutto,
era un'ossessione.
Cioé io... non cercate di convincermi
che io mi convincevo di sapere tutto.
No, io sapevo tutto.
Sapevo tutto ed ero così pronta
a rispondere alla domanda.
"Cosa vuoi fare da grande, Beatrice?"
Io, da grande, voglio andare a New York
e fare l'illustratrice. Wow!
Bene, quella era la mia risposta
agli otto anni, ai 12 anni, ai 16 anni,
cioé qui comincia ad essere sospetta
la cosa, ai 19 anni e lo volevo tanto,
era una menzione così bruciante,
che a vent'anni
ottenni una borsa di studio
di migliaia di dollari
per studiare
in una delle università più famose
per l'illustrazione che ci sia.
Mi si stava avverando l'ambizione
di una vita, no?
Allora presi l'aereo e due giorni dopo
essere arrivata a New York mi innamorai.
Sono catastrofi.
Nove mesi dopo aspettavo un bambino.
La cosa più curiosa
è che ero veramente felice.
Felice come non lo ero mai stata prima,
e non sapevo nemmeno
come definire questa cosa.
Abbandonai la borsa di studio,
abbandonai la scuola,
abbandonai una città in cui
non ero felice.
Mi sentii come se avessi saltato
da un treno in corsa
e mi sentii come se avessi scoperto
che l'atterraggio non è poi tanto duro.
Ma due anni e mezzo dopo,
due anni e mezzo dopo di vita,
vita non facile,
perché nessuno ha mai detto
che la vita debba essere facile,
come non ho detto
che la vita... la via più facile
sia quella giusta.
Due anni e mezzo dopo,
ricevetti una lettera da una persona
che stimo molto,
un' illustratrice,
e mi scrisse: "Beatrice",
col cuore in mano, "Beatrice, se non studi
ti ci vorrà tantissimo tempo
a diventare una grandissima artista".
Io volli riflettere
su quel significato di tempo.
Se io dovessi impiegare 200 anni
d'impegno a capire che cos'è l'arte,
sarà valsa la pena.
Se io dopo 200 anni, ancora,
non avrò capito che cos'è l'arte,
ma avrò messo impegno
e passione in quella cosa,
sarà valsa la pena comunque.
Perché è la mia vita, il mio tempo,
perché è la vostra vita, il vostro tempo.
Allora, vorrei parlare del tempo,
vorrei parlare del modo in cui
questo mondo ha bisogno del nostro tempo,
ha bisogno che noi sacrifichiamo
del tempo, e vorrei parlarne.
Le slides sono rimaste fisse da un po'.
Vorrei parlarne attraverso le slides.
Questo prenderà un po' di tempo,
perché le mie slides sono molto lente
e devo andare quasi alla fine,
andrò avanti.
Scusate, alcune cose
che non vi ho mostrato
perché ho deciso di andare avanti.
Avanti.
Ora ve lo dico,
era una metafora per descrivere
i nostri sogni che si ingrandiscono.
Eccoci!
Bene.
Per spiegare a me stessa il significato
del tempo in questo mondo,
volevo fare un grafico,
poi non riuscii
a fare un grafico, non sono brava,
allora feci una serie di vignette.
Questa è la legenda
per capire le vignette.
Vediamo... un sacco di denaro,
i nostri anni di vita in una busta
e un certificato.
Questi siamo noi, siamo noi
di fronte al direttore universitario,
pieni di speranze, offriamo cinque anni
della nostra vita,
del denaro,
in cambio di un certificato.
Ora andiamo avanti.
Questi siamo noi.
Abbiamo trovato un lavoro,
ora offriamo 40 anni della nostra vita
e un certificato
in cambio di denaro.
Questi siamo noi.
Siamo noi con i nervi a pezzi
e le spalle rotte, scusate il pessimismo,
e offriamo 16 anni della nostra vita
e quattro decenni di contributi pagati
in cambio di... una pensione.
Ragazzi questo è il lieto fine,
che per me suona un po' come:
"Lei adesso è arrivato alla fine
dei suoi giorni, si goda l'ultimo tempo
in santa pace,
non le romperemo più le scatole.
Ma io, che ogni tanto gioco a fare
la pessimista,
ho pensato a un altro finale.
Chi ci dice come sarà il mondo
tra 40 anni?
tra 6, 5, 4 decenni?
Come sarà il concetto di lavoro
tra tutto quel tempo?
Per me queste sono domande
molto molto importanti
perché, forse perché ho ancora 24 anni
e forse perché ho un bambino
di 2 anni e mezzo?
Io me lo chiedo e mi chiedo
il valore delle nostre scelte.
Non ho parlato di intuizione mai,
ora menzionerò la parola intuizione
perché ovviamente è la nostra intuizione
che ci porta poi a fare delle scelte.
Ho ancora due minuti di tempo,
prima di andare a svenire
nell'altra stanza, vi dedico una storia.
Anzi, la dedico a chiunque si sia sentito,
almeno una volta nella vita,
in dovere di compiere una scelta
che non gli apparteneva.
Vi è un treno lunghissimo
che emette vapori dorati
e corre a velocità infernali.
Ragazzo che stai per salire sul treno,
se hai dei dubbi, aspetta.
Ragazzo che sei salito sul treno
e senti che il tuo posto non è lì,
scendi. Scendi, scendi!
Come? Salta!
Salta dal tetto del treno e scoprirai
che non fa poi tanto male.
E nel momento in cui apri gli occhi
e ti accorgi che puoi camminare,
alzati, alzati e vedi
che i lividi passano,
i dolori scompaiono.
Hai saltato, sei sceso dal treno
e finalmente hai capito
che il tuo posto nel mondo è qui.
Semplicemente qui.
Attorno a te, altre persone.
Perché sono stati in tanti a saltar giù
prima di te.
Benvenuto.